I rescued George he was 2 years old he's
not just a friend he's family got your
message about George he okay I don't
know George
is it mirrors he considerably bigger no
he's definitely bigger what's happening
to my friend are you familiar with
genetic editing someone's mutating
animals into monsters your oversized
monkey is old news
of course the wolf flies
let's go save the world that's a big arm
don't fight it
you know there are other ways of dealing
with people right I do know that yeah
but that's no fun
rampage experienced it in IMAX April
20th it's weird you like hang out with
animals more than people yeah
well animals get me a rescue George he
was two years old George never would
have survived on his own he definitely
trusts you last night
George was seven feet away five hundred
pounds
George you okay buddy you're scared it's
okay this morning is nine feet pushing a
thousand what's happening to my friend
are you familiar with genetic editing
changes will be incredibly unpredictable
is he the only one oh you didn't know
about the 30-foot wolf hello today huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's big
mistake I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me
you have to evacuate Chicago George
didn't ask for this they're gonna put
them down
that's not happening
[Music]
there's something in the river I was
just thinking the only thing that's
missing right now is the giant crocodile
you